oxygen is alert now Maryland health
officials say the state may be
approaching the peak of its outbreak
finally as social distancing helps
flatten that curve Maryland currently
has more than 5500 cases though and more
than 120 deaths
joining me now the governor of Maryland
Larry Hogan governor good morning to you
good morning good morning it good to see
you and you'll have to forgive me if the
Governor Cuomo here in New York may be
having a news conference in a few
moments he's a Democrat has gotten high
marks for what he has done you're a
Republican you've gotten higher marks
for what you've done on the ground you
acted early and tried to deal with this
tell me what's happening at this hour in
your state so our numbers continue to
climb we're a couple of weeks behind New
York but we took really aggressive and
early action in our state and we're
hoping to lessen the problems here but
in the Baltimore Washington corridor
we're now at about 12,000 we're probably
about 50 or six in the nation we've got
about five million people in between
those two cities and our numbers
continue to rise fairly rapidly it's not
nearly at the kind of situation you have
in New York but it's an area that now we
got the federal government focused on as
the Washington Metropolitan Area all the
way through to Baltimore and our our
state's got a pretty good population
center right there surrounding those two
those two cities where we've got issues
and it's growing rapidly what are you
seeing in terms of hospitalizations
because here in New York that you
mentioned Louisiana as well we spoke to
some officials there earlier this
morning they were going through maybe
what you're going through now a few days
ago a week ago and they're now seeing
hospitalizations new new patients going
into the hospital coming down are you
lagging behind them where
hospitalizations are still going up yeah
so we're maybe 10 days to two weeks
behind New York and and Louisiana but
we're hoping to not nearly be as bad
because we took actions several weeks
earlier than they did so I was the first
governor in America to declare a state
of emergency one of the first first or
second to close all of the schools
statewide we've been really aggressive
for the past 35 days and we are hoping
that's going to dampen some of these
numbers but we're definitely at the
beginning of the climb as opposed to
sort of at the apex where we believe
they are and there
hopefully starting to flatten out we're
hoping our climb isn't as steep but
we're still a couple of weeks away 10
days 14 days from reaching the top got
it and what about the health care
workers were on the front lines they've
been doing heroic work in every state
all across the country do they have the
gear they need in your state well
they're just incredible they're putting
their lives on the line for the rest of
us and in my heart goes out to them my
appreciation goes out to them and we're
doing everything we possibly can to get
them the protective equipment that they
need a mask and the shields and the
gowns but it's a it's a difficult
situation that we're all dealing with in
every one of our states and we're
working with our federal partners and
each of the states as being as
aggressive as they can to help our
hospitals and our hospital systems get
the things that we need to those health
care workers that are on the front lines
last question in terms of figuring out
the schools moving forward some
governors and said look they're probably
done for the entire year others saying
they're hoping to get some school time
back I have to admit I have a conflict
of interest here because my daughter
Mila wants to know if you'll be able to
help her with her homework there in
Bethesda but in all seriousness what's
happening on the ground with the school
sir well I'd be happy to help her with
her homework a little bit but we haven't
really made the final decision yet on
schools schools usually are ending here
in the middle of June we're gonna wait
and see over the next couple of weeks
exactly where we are how much we're able
to flatten this curve and what happens
but the state school superintendent is
working with all of our 24 local school
superintendents to try to make those
decisions and in the meantime they're
trying to do distance learning as much
as possible yeah online and sending home
school plans we're doing the best we can
we'd like we'd love to get them back
open but we don't want to do that if
it's not safe well I've been getting the
emails you've been getting laptops to
people who need them to get that
distance-learning going I know there's
been a lot of rough days but you're
dealing with a monumental task and doing
it well we appreciate all you're doing
and governor good luck in the days ahead